the Joe Rogan experience I encouraged
too many people to do too many things I
encourage everybody to start a podcast I
encourage everybody to do stand-up I do
it all the time and I people who get mad
at me going you should encourage
everybody to do it but if you try it you
might be good at it
like it's not a special talent in the
sense that like if you look if you can't
run fast you're not gonna win a
track-and-field you're not you're just
not the almost anybody who thinks
they're funny who loves comedies got a
sense of humor and is smart can at least
make some attempts at stand-up and I
think if you can just get a little bit
of traction get going a little bit you
can get better everybody's got a
different pace your pace was faster
because you had been talking [ __ ] your
whole life right but other guys like
we're more silent and introverted it
took them a little while to get their
thing going but if they can do it even
if they do it they gotta keep doing it
yes you gotta keep you can't just like
just you know like that guy my friend
it's the grind some people can't grind I
started I started I you know I didn't
start my podcast start started but I
recorded one today Wow
by myself it's a 44 minutes do you just
do a Bill burr style the reason why the
reason why I did it because I didn't
want you to talk [ __ ] down I was like
this I was like this [ __ ] got a
knockout punch so listen you're so good
you're so good on podcast for you to not
have a podcast as a atrocity but I did
it for four I'd this is the first time
of my life I talked for 45 minutes with
nobody else but myself
perfect this is the first time I ever
did that it's easy for you you could
stay in his room for three hours and
just go I'm Way better off with people
but you can do it like you could go to
distance you could just do whatever but
it's a thing that you get better at
doing that's all it is it's like
everything else I could be being on a
pot like doing podcast is the thing that
gets you you get better at being on a
podcast you get better at doing it I
think I might have fun yeah it's um but
I knew I couldn't go in here listen
coming here but now I'll show you the
time oh I knew it was the year so it was
like five months ago so every time I see
you I just want to say what's up like
stretch it out and [ __ ] he's like what's
up with that podcast I'm like man I try
to be something you know my son has a
birthday yeah that's cool everybody has
a birthday what's up with that podcast
this which is what I say
this is whatever and I really mean it
everybody like the one of the reasons
why I encourage every comic to do it
because if you just put some energy into
it you have a thing that's all you and
if it's successful it's all you it's you
it's like you and you don't have to
worry about getting fired you don't to
worry about it people being mad at you
it's you
I know it's putting out but me not used
to talking to himself but you could talk
to a friend I don't I couldn't I didn't
have a friend than Sonny I'm if you
don't want to talk to me I do you want
yours first
all right and then we can come and do
mine second day I deal one today how
about we do one today I just did one
okay I just did when I got 44 minutes
okay I did one and I'm gonna tell you it
started off I don't know I was honest
listen I want you to critique and say
okay you got a critique you say okay I
just I think you just kind of put him
out of the first ones aren't your
favorite ones it doesn't matter but that
made me i'ma tell you I felt I was
excited cuz you wouldn't be to talk [ __ ]
to me I was I was like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
this [ __ ]
I was excited he was about to get on
podcast and I decided that I got 45
minutes of me talking that's beautiful
and this is a start I'm telling the
truth
yeah if you go back and listen to the
earlybird ones who would do it on a
phone he would like to make a phone call
to a place and like it would be him on
the phone it wasn't even like a recorder
on his phone like if this builders first
ones he was doing way back before there
was like an app on your phone that you
could record on yeah talking [ __ ] about
people at the airport just talking [ __ ]
about this guy look at this [ __ ] guy
[ __ ] son
I'm sure you're a [ __ ] master at it
man I'm 100% should have a podcast 44
minutes well more people do it the more
comics do it the more it empowers all
all right what do I got to do now I just
gotta do is get it in account you need a
an account where you can get an RSS feed
somehow don't don't panic I want to do
it now man we'll help you we'll help you
I'll help you Susie's gonna do it man
you gonna help you John the more I
produced my first one that's all I ask I
just get one yes yes Jamie
we'll do it do it bootleggers [ __ ] we'll
do it come on Jamie don't worry I'll
take care of it Darnell is that a yes or
no yes no man is it yes we got you I
will first 144 minutes I'll have it
super easy to set up so you just have to
upload one every week it'll be easy okay
we'll get it we'll get it started
I'm you promise right 100% him and me
okay we're gonna go through this
together we're gonna make it happen I'm
not forgetting you I'm gonna do more but
I got one ready gonna you're gonna do
more help I was honest good beautiful I
love you sir I love you too man I get
happy when I see you make it happen I
see you too oh my god to be working out
everywhere I go does [ __ ]
everywhere you at every club site gotta
work how can you not win you kind of
work yeah I mean don't you think that's
the thing just puttin his numbers how
can you and it's so funny because and be
nice be nice because when we did that
show like we all did a good job right
yeah but it felt good because we knew
like we have put the reps in yeah you
know I'm saying it wasn't like this like
swinging haymakers it's like no
[ __ ]
we gotta tone down I got this [ __ ] yeah
yeah we did the Utah joint yep that was
so dope because you know we did the
first one Ashley you I mean Ashley Andy
you and then they had the intermission
at me and Dave and then on the Utah
joint it was daytime right that's right
- wait I'm like we didn't wait right so
I'm like this cuz I just experienced
something similar to you before with
Frankie Beverly and maze basically
[ __ ] when dear and it was
daytime you know and I was like this you
can't give Joe mother
daytime audience like it's the backstage
at a festival is legit right I was like
oh man is she gonna get dark and I went
on then and he got dark and [ __ ] you
wouldn't be a dish it up it was fun it
was amazing those gigs were special man
like they felt like they felt historic
they thought we were doing something
really fun yeah you know which one is
this one Oh Utah was beautiful
they're both beautiful look at this yeah
the sky and everything above it it was
perfect
they were both beautiful I [ __ ] love
you Tom and I like going there look at
that [ __ ] they're gonna BAM
but that you don't I'm saying like those
shows felt special that felt like we're
doing some fun [ __ ] man that [ __ ] is
like it is you man you that energy that
energy like it's like it was like [ __ ] I
would want to see like if I if I was a
guy who likes stand-up who didn't do it
I want it I want to see that show and
it's the show and then I see him other
people enjoy the show I don't say to
somebody hey we were at the Rogen
Chapelle show you know no it was fun man
it's dope it was real fun good do more
of those huh I'm starting my pot you got
me started
oh you promised son you said you do
promise you said I don't do promises I'm
gonna take care of it
I know that's why I had to take care of
it we just you open up a branch that
would annoy the [ __ ] out of people right
well hire a whole separate group of
people so we can help people get podcast
launched people but there's two [ __ ]
news you said you're gonna do mine I'm
good you're the first one that's all
this is I'm a concentrated a hundred
percent on you know what I'm saying I
mean if we did decide to do that to have
a branch where just helped people get
started with their [ __ ] but then the
people too many people to ask then you
would have like no you gotta pick it you
got a pig but ten people get mad at you
you don't pick but don't nobody give a
[ __ ] you dealing with some like record
producer type [ __ ] you find a horse in
your bed right like a yearly dress
Oh yearly drag that yeah so much work we
just produce yours
we just Purdue that's it ma'am just mine
yeah yeah what was I thinking
señores is young fans started [ __ ]
book trying to bully me a shed yeah I
was in Orlando and all these
[ __ ] look like you kept coming
up they love you they look like just
like you man
they look like you a walk like you they
just like you they are you saying they
come up talk about what the [ __ ] is up
with the pocket yeah that's the truth
that's hilarious well we gotcha we're
rolling alright facial you hurting here
folks ladies and gentlemen whoo that's
it we're rolling yeah hundred percent
you got me i'ma do it
[Applause]